this thing keeps happening every single
time I listen to one of my favorite
songs in the last five years or so I
hear this weird but familiar drum sound
that just cuts right through the track I
love it
here it is one more time
that punchy unnatural drum was the sound
of the 80s and it's back
it's called gated reverb and like many
of the greatest inventions it was
discovered by accident
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the 1970s drums on the radio sounded
a lot like this they quite dry only then
just as recoded to achieve that isolated
clean sound producers and engineers
miked the drums all over including the
inside this is the sound of bands like
Pink Floyd Earth Wind & Fire and Genesis
at least up until 1979
that's when Peter Gabriel was recording
his third solo album his Genesis
bandmate Phil Collins was on the drums
playing a simple beat and here's where
something magical happened so according
to their engineer Hugh Padgham they had
a brand new recording console with some
cool features that included a mic
hanging in the studio to talk to the
band that Mike accidentally picked up
Phil's drums and the result was this
thick punchy reverb that disappeared in
an instant the reason well the mic had a
heavy compressor on it which reduces the
volume of loud sounds and amplifies
quiet ones
it sort of crunches a waveform and the
console had a noise gate which only lets
amplitudes above a certain threshold
pass through and then it immediately
shuts off the result was such a crazy
sound that Peter Gabriel wrote his album
opener intruder around it
[Music]
now if you don't know intruder you'll
certainly recognize this made by Phil
Collins and Hugh Padgham a year later
thanks to a happy accident sound of the
80s was born
the drums on in the air tonight were
recorded in town houses legendary stone
room its reverb came from the walls of
the studio it was meant to sound like a
castle but not everybody who wanted good
reverb had access to that type of space
in the 80s once the digital technology
came to the fore not only was the sound
of our music changing but the things
that augment our sounds were changing
also nothing illustrates this more than
the evolution of reverb so reverb was
achieved in the early days the most
natural way of all which is to have an
echo chamber so what you would do in
this chamber is you would set up in one
corner of the room a big loudspeaker and
then the other corner of the room we had
set up a microphone here's an echo
chamber at Abbey Road Studios echo
chambers took up real estate and real
estate was expensive so plate reverb was
invented would be a big box with an
aluminium plate in it and the voice
would go in one side travel along the
aluminium plate and come out the other
side with a little bit of reverberation
on it plate reverb boxes were 600 pounds
or more not great for portability enter
the AMS RM x16 a shoebox size unit that
created reverb vias circuit boards and
algorithms right there in a box
we had plate reverb and underground
garages and big concert halls and small
and large echo chambers and music clubs
the AMS which debuted in 1982 was the
first reverb unit to be driven by a
microprocessor and it had room for 99
presets including a few that created
that unnatural gated sound with a push
of a button
I think a big example was the work that
I did with prints in the eighties he
loved that gated reverb but yes that
Prince Prince used a linn lm-1 drum
machine that sampled real drum sounds
susan fed that linn lm-1 to the AMS
reverb box and used a preset called
non-linear no nonlinear reverb just
can't be replicated in the real world
without technology reverb in a natural
setting tends to
as the audio signal decays nonlinear
reverb it actually it's louder it makes
a drum sound like a whip picture it like
a tidal wave a huge wave suddenly
stopping and hitting a brick wall that's
the sound of gated reverb that was the
classic quintessential example that was
the big one that was the fat one a year
after in the air tonight those huge
drums were no longer an accident the
sound was just built into the reverb
technology and for a decade did reverb
which is a sound you couldn't escape on
the radio
[Music]
we really kind of used it to death and
buy the next album I sign of the times
that was pretty sick of it
it seemed everybody else was too when
the 90s rolled around musicians tended
to favor those dry drums again but
here's the thing after about a 20-year
hiatus its back
here's Ariel rechtshaid on song exploder
he produced carly Rae Jepsen's latest
album that drum fill is just something
that I've always kind of had in my head
they were inspired by the drum fill in a
Jack and Diane by John Cougar Mellencamp
[Music]
Jack Antonoff of bleachers was born the
Year Prince released Purple Rain and
here he is in a studio playing that linn
lm-1 drum machine he produced the Lord's
latest album which has gated reverb
drums and Taylor Swift's Athlete titled
1989 the thing is producers today don't
need prince's drum machine or a physical
rack of reverb units to get that 8e
sound you can go online and download
massive prints and Phil Collins inspired
gated reverb drum sample packs and that
AMS RM x16 it's how a computer plug-in
sure gated reverb drums aren't a
timeless sound they bring you back to
the 80s but that doesn't mean they don't
sound cool this episode of your work is
brought to you by audible if you don't
have all the calm there are so many
amazing books about music but there's
one that I definitely want to recommend
and that's listen to this by alex ross
alex ross is a longtime music critic at
the new yorker and he's written some of
my favorite books about music if you
want to understand music more or
appreciate it better listen to this
definitely has you covered so if you go
to audible.com
you can download a 30-day free trial
download listen to this for free and if
you choose not to keep the service you
can still keep the book one other thing
is I made a Spotify playlist for you the
link is in the description is called an
ode to gated reverb and it has some of
my favorite songs with gated reverb from
the 1980s and today
[Music]